اوكرانيا تطلب التبرعات من اجل القوارب
نعم لكنها تطلب التبرعات في العموم
للمساعده في الحرب امر يظهر لنا جانبا اخر
من التكنولوجيا الهجينه البيتكوين تحول
الى رصاصنا وقودا وسطره واقيه واكرانيا
شكرت مجتمع العملات المشفره على المساعده
شركه اف تي اكس التي كما نعلم اعلنت
افلاسها كانت حاضره منذ مارس مع الحكومه
الاوكرانيه وهذا امر معلن تبرعاتا لكيف
بالعملات المشفره المنصه التي تم اطلاقها
جامعه بالفعل 60 مليون دولار لدعمني
اوكرانيا بحلول مايا وكان قد صوريفا نحو
54 مليون للحصول على المعدات الحربيه
وهناك فجوه باكثر من خمسه ملايين سنتحدث
عنها لاحقا مشاهدينا لكن هناك امر اخر جاء
على الشهور بجانبي كل ما اثير حول اكس
اجعلها تتزايد اخيرا قيام حدثت منصه جمع
التبرعات قبل ثلاثه ايام من اعلان بنك مان
افلاسه حكومه زينسكي فتحت منصه اخرى دون
اي اشاره لافت اكس وهنا ظهرت حرب اخرى ليس
في اوكرانيا وانما في الولايات المتحده
بنكمان اف تي اكس متهمني بغسل اموال
المساعدات الامريكيه لاوكرانيا ولصالح من
لصالح الديمقراطيين النبي حسب الاتهامات
الاموال التي دفعها بايضا ان تعود لها كيف
المساعدات الاوكرانيا تستخدمها الاخيره في
اكس ثم يتم التبرع بها لتمويل الحزب
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه لا دلائل كثيره حتى
الان سوى الفجوه التي ذكرناها قبل قليل
خمسه ملايين وخمسمائه الف دولار ما بين
المقدم والمصروف لكن التقارير التي تشير
الى ذلك تستند الى عدده الشواهد
اولا بنكمان اسس شركه اف تي اكس في ابريل
2019 نفس الشهر الذي اعلن فيه بيضا الترشح
للرئاسه ثانيا في اطار حملته بانك مان منح
اكثر من 5 ملايين للمجموعات التي تدعم
بايظن ومنها حمله تلفزيونيه مدتها 11 ساعه
تستهدف الولايات المتاحه لجعل العمله
المشفره ثاني اكبر منيحا الي بعدا ثالثا
في عام 2022 العام الحالي ان فقط ما
يقربوا من 40 مليون دولار على المرشحين
الديمقراطيين والحملات ولجان العمل
السياسي ورابعا اعلنت اف تي اكس ال
الافلاس بعد الانتخابات النصفيه دليل
واربعه شواهد لكن ماذا يقول البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]